all right so here's a really Charming
one what's the area of this semi-circle
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you two ways to solve this one way
which I think is very uh clever and fast
and then a second way which is kind of
like oh if you didn't spot the the
really clever way of doing things this
then that's okay there is another way to
go about it slightly longer but it's
still doable
so what's the area of the semicircle in
order to work out the area of a circle
semicircle quadrant anything basically
Circle related you're gonna need to the
the size of the circle which is its
radius right now what's tricky about
this diagram is as presented there's no
labeled radius on here right uh I mean I
could find where the center of the
circle is and then measure but the four
and the six and the two I don't know how
they all relate to the radius none of
them is the radius and so really this is
a question of find the radius and
that'll give you the area of the
semicircle or at least find the square
of the radius that'll do the job okay
now the way I'm going to go about this
is there's a like I said a bit of a
trick to noticing this and if you
haven't already pause the video have a
go at this yourself it's actually
um really enjoyable and and more richly
rewarding if you can go through and do
the thinking
um to find a solution yourself before I
show you one but if you've had a well um
or if you have no pen and paper nearby
and you're like I'm not going to give
this a go I don't want to use my stuffy
finger try and draw on my smartphone or
something like that then I'm going to
show you how I went about this
I notice that there's this length four
and two here and this this length six
which is well it's the sum of two and
four now how can I use that fact what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this length of six here and I'm going to
break it up into a length two and a
length four now you might say why would
you do that and it's because I'm going
to create
some right angle triangles that are
related to each other so let's uh let's
use some see if I can pick out some
matching colors here all right so
actually I'll make it a bit thicker I
think this one will do so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to like I said pick
an arbitrary spot
somewhere in the middle there it's not
exactly arbitrary it's a spot that
divides up the six into a two and a four
right so you can see I've tried to do
the the ratios there and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to draw in a
hypotenuse for this triangle over on the
left hand side
uh remembering that what I did was I
said I want this to be equal to 2 and
then I'm also going to draw a hypotenuse
I think I need to make this a bit
thicker
over on the right hand side
like so and then this triangle has a 4
in it okay so what I've done is I don't
know where this point is but I know that
there has to be a point that I can
divide in a two to four or a one to two
ratio because they add up to six okay
now have a look at these two triangles
that we've created because there's some
really important facts about them for
starters they are both right angled you
can see them from the right angles on
the outsides of the two and the four
I've just sort of used the fact that
angles on a straight line equal to 180
degrees or they add up to 180 degrees I
should say and so therefore on either
side you're going to have these 90s on
either side of those vertical lines okay
so they're both right angled
and in addition to both being right
angled they both have an identical pair
of lengths on either side of the right
angle right so what I've got here is a
side angle side relationship side angle
side in other words what I've created is
two triangles that are congruent to each
other two triangles that are congruent
to each other so they're identical uh in
size and in in ratios and all that kind
of thing they're just in different
places maybe they are flipped over or
rotated or a bit of both right
so what that tells us is if you have a
look at their hypoten users I think
that's the plural right let's call this
hypotenuse H and uh you have a look at
the other hypotenuse over here because
these triangles are congruent their
hypotenusees both have to be the same
does that make sense so um this
hypotenuse in this hypotenuse have to be
equal to each other but but hold on if
you have a look closely right both of
these triangles have a Vertex or a
corner
on the circumference of the circle right
so what I've done is I've I've noticed
that from the circumference of the
circle to some point inside the circle
you say that again from uh the
circumference to the inside of the
circle and you know that this is a
diameter because the question told told
you this is a semicircle right so this
is not just any chord it is the diameter
there's only one place on the diameter
of the circle where you can go to the
circumference and it'd be equidistant
the only place that works on the
diameter where you can say oh it's the
equal distance to other points on the
circumference that's the center that is
the center of the circle right there so
in fact what you found is that these
hypotenuses are not just random
hypotenuses these are in fact I can
replace those H's
with ours these are both radii so just
have a think about this for a second
what I've used is just a little bit of
logic to do with congruent triangles to
prove that these two hypotenuses are the
radii and of course I can use good
old-fashioned Pythagoras's Theorem to
evaluate that radius because they're the
hypotenuse and then that'll give me the
area of the semicircle I hope that's
following and that makes sense let's
actually do those calculations
I can say 2 squared plus 4 squared
equals r squared so that gives me 4 16
that's r squared there I didn't even
need to work out what the square root of
Ira is because
to find out the area of a semicircle
area of semicircle
I need r squared anyway so even if I
took the square root you'd be squaring
it back anyway and you'd get back to
this value of 20. so it's going to be
half because it's a semicircle pi r
squared but we just said that r squared
was 20 so therefore it's half pi times
20 and that gives me 10 pi and it's
units squared okay so like I said it's
very cute you can see it's delightful to
have such a um An Elegant piece of
working there's very little uh kind of
lines of of algebra required
but maybe you might say any that's a bit
weird though that that whole trick that
you pull with congruent triangles the
whole idea of picking a weirdo spot that
was two plus four equals six like I
didn't see that at all right well if
you're feeling like that don't feel bad
because when I first solved this problem
I didn't see it either so I went about
it a different way you're going to see
that as we attack this question again
it's going to take slightly more working
um but not a lot more and what's great
about it is you don't have to um you
don't have to pull that mystery rabbit
out of a hat move that I mentioned
before with the congruent triangles so
let's uh wipe this Lake clean mentally
reapproach this question the area of the
semicircles what we're after and these
just these three lengths are all that
we've been given okay so what can I do
here
well what I'm going to do instead is I'm
still going to pick a point on this
length 6 here but I'm actually going to
pick it a bit more specifically rather
than use this two plus four equals six
business I'm just going to say hey this
is the diameter right so therefore the
center of the circle is somewhere on the
diameter so let's just call that there
I'm going to Define it as o now right so
this differs from my previous approach
which was that I deduced that this point
here was O based on the argument I made
before with congruent triangles
hypotenesis and radii here I've gone
about it by saying I'm going to Define
this as o O's on the on the diameter
somewhere so I'm going to place that
point there but I don't know therefore
what uh that's not what I want to do I
don't know what either of these lengths
on either side of O are equal to right I
know all the way to the circumference is
the radius that's the thing I'm trying
to find right but I don't know what say
like this little length in here is if I
were to highlight this
oops
so say say this length here I I don't
know what that is because
um I I don't know anything about the the
breakup proportions just because that's
the center right so being that I do not
know what that's equal to I'm just going
to call it X and what that tells me is
since the whole purple
um we got given in the first place
um is six therefore this remaining part
here is the difference so it must be six
take away X like so
now again just carrying on my logic
remember in this approach to the problem
I've defined oh I've said that's the
center of the circle which means that
when I go from the center up to uh this
point on the circumference here by
definition this is the radius because
it's coming from the center of the
circle and same deal when I go over to
here so these are both radii because I
defined the center of the circle knowing
that it has to be somewhere on the
diameter right
so now I've got all my pieces of the
puzzle I still want to find what the
radius is but I'm going to have to use
the fact that the radius is in both of
these right angle triangles and relate
things together so let's have a go
you can see if I have a look at the left
hand triangle what I've got is by
Pythagoras 4 squared plus x squared
equals r squared so there's the
Pythagoras relationship
going over to the other triangle what
I've got instead of 4 squared and x
squared the shorter lengths are 2
squared and 6 take away x squared that's
also equal to r squared because that's
the hypotenuse right so if I take these
two
which I know independently from the two
right angle triangles I can substitute
one into the other and that's going to
eliminate out R now you might say Eddie
why you were eliminating out r r is the
thing that you want to find well if I
eliminate R I create a single equation
which has a single unknown in this case
I should use this color in this case
it's the X and I can use that to then
work out the r because these two
equations both have r squared as a
subject it makes more sense to cancel
that out first and we will return back
to R obviously I need it to work out the
area
so I'm going to say let's substitute
one into two
and that is going to give me a quadratic
in X that you're going to see it's not
going to stay a quadratic for very long
so I've got 4 squared plus x squared on
one side two squared plus 6 take away x
squared on the other side all right so
let's begin to disentangle this I'll
start evaluating some numbers here 16 4.
what have I got here so this is going to
be 3x take away 12x plus x squared and I
said before this is a quadratic because
we've got x squared but I have exactly
1X squared on the right and exactly one
x squared on the left so they are going
to cancel with each other and that's
good to know because it means I just get
left with a linear equation in X and
then the rest of it is just constants so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to add
12x to both sides I can see here
I've got uh 40 take away 16 so that
gives me 24 so I've got uh x equals 2
which by the way if you looked at the
previous one you're like oh I knew that
X was equal to 2 because we had done
this logic before but I didn't I didn't
know I hadn't proven it using this
approach right so different flow of
logic but that's one of the reassuring
things about mathematics you'll always
end up with the same answer
and so from here what do I do with that
well my my instinct is you would
substitute that x value into the
simplest equation that relates x with r
which in this case is equation one up
here you can see I can just put that 2
in there and it'll leave me with r
squared so I will substitute X into
equation one which gives me 16 plus 4
equals r squared r squared equals 20
like you saw before and I'm not even
going to keep on going there because you
know what happens from here I just do
half pi r squared and there's the answer